foreign
[Music]
of the computer
all right what are we on what are we on
episode one six 117.
welcome listeners who's young young and
old from far and wide
from the occident to the Orient
individuals and masses the math the math
it is the mass audience we are on a kick
we're on a kick seeking out wherever we
may find it the different forms of
post-marxism and trying to find someone
that we like
I haven't I haven't heard their first
impressions yet but this was my
recommendation because
this got me woke this beauderard woke me
woke you to what to things that I
already believed which is
so much of what we say is [__] why
don't we just admit it I totally felt
like I was some some of the passages I
was reading like in my brain it was just
pills's voice
a compliment I take that as a as a
profound compliment oh I wish I could
talk like this guy this is 1980s body
art
so he wasn't in he wasn't totally crazy
yet
he was in the process of becoming crazy
but because a lot of people have heard
me talk about this I don't know about
this text but this air era at least of
Border I wanted to hear your first
impressions right off the bat before I
editorialize what my thoughts were so
Victor especially I I was wondering
where you'd fall on this because this is
often the type of writing that you hate
the most but you seem to give a somewhat
toe in the water positive response as
the uh political philosopher
and lib
so what did you think of what did you
think of 80s
overall I enjoyed reading it I did think
that there were some things about it
that
um I either didn't understand or felt
like
annoyingly written but starting with the
things that I liked about it so I found
myself broadly agreeing with kind of the
the challenge she seems to situate the
challenge of mobilizing any kind of a
masses or like getting people to do
anything or like kind of trying to sort
of
uh debunk the idea that there is
anything that resembles some inner power
in human beings to mobilize and do
something great it's kind of like he's
taking a big [__] on on that
and to some extent I enjoyed that
um because to some extent my work does
that too I would say that there's
something about this
that I felt went a little too far at
times and
kind of he does this thing that I think
all theory of this broad genre do
is make these really large General
pronouncements about the way Society is
shaping and that everything can be
reduced to spectacle because it's all
just simulation and simulation is
you know nothing there's no and it's
just these broad pronouncements where
sometimes I was like yeah
I think that's there's something to that
but other times I was kind of like
really and I guess the issue I sometimes
have
with that is maybe it's just a matter of
taste or preference some kind of like
aesthetic preference that I have
but I like specificity like I like to
know what are you specifically talking
about and when theorists make really
broad pronouncements to kind of Define
the age and Define the time and Define
the culture in these broad large
categories
I feel like I'm getting a really like
low resolution the analogy in my mind is
always just like really pixelated
resolution of what the world is like
where it's like kind of giving me a
shape of the way the world is but the
pixels are really big and I'm just like
yeah kind of but I don't know there's
like a lack of specificity but I liked
it I mean I I think there is some some
amusing Parts in it about like people
not Desiring anything and kind of
seems like there's some mocking of
certain views and it was like fun to
read even if I didn't always disagree
with even if I didn't always agree with
it and yeah like I did like the way that
he was pointing out
um a lot of the ways in which people and
the masses you know we shouldn't have so
much faith I guess in the masses in the
possibilities and I was sympathetic to
that but I also kind of felt like before
we started recording we were talking
about this as post-marxism and I was
kind of thinking it's just going so far
sometimes where it's just like post
anything it's like post-rationality post
agency it's just like kind of saying
like nothing's possible except just a
kind of self-perpetuating simulation and
spectacle
um and then and I find myself not
strongly disagreeing but just kind of
agnostic because of that low resolution
thing where I'm like yeah maybe I don't
know it's maybe a little bit too
religious for you it does rely on
religious metaphors
lots of God lots of last judgment
anyway Eric do you have a general
pronouncement
I mean if I were to predict your
reaction to this I would have not a clue
what to say oh no I couldn't predict no
yeah I I kind of agree I'm not sure what
Eric's gonna make of this I I feel like
this is
yeah this is like Ground Zero for me I
mean I started with postmodernism in my
in my education I mean in some ways yeah
I did because I came into literature
right so that's how we divide up the
phases of literature you have kind of
Romanticism modernism and then
post-modernism so it's just it's just
accepted in in the field I was brought
up in that these are the divisions right
because you see very different Trends
going on in modernist literature you
know whatever Virginia Woolf
Hemingway Faulkner et cetera then you
and then you see very different Trends
emerging in the 50s and 60s and
they relate these to similar things
right like technological scientific
progress the bomb World War II cat
Advanced capitalism I mean this stuff
makes sense to me
in tracking these cultural trends
I'm not as experienced with like
confronting it on the level of
philosophy as opposed to kind of like
postmodern Aesthetics I get I get the
aesthetic background a little better
than I get the philosophical side of it
but I mean beauji yards like kind of
Ground Zero for me I read the system of
objects years ago
which was like 20 years before this text
we're reading
um but he's on to similar things right
we I I specifically read the part on
collection and collection uh being like
a collector and collection objects where
you take them out of circulation and you
kind of arrange them on your shelves and
their value completely transforms
but I found that very fascinating
because I was doing a material culture
course so yeah read the system of
objects and we had discussions in class
and it was actually really interesting
because it was like what are you into
and one guy was into oh my God what
actor was it like collecting every
single Nicholas Cage movie on DVD or
something like that like people just
came out with these extremely weird
things they're into you just ask
somebody like hey do you collect stuff
and you might be surprised by that and I
don't know read the system of objects
and he kind of gives you like a broad
understanding of of like items and and
capitalist circulation versus like the
kind of collector networks which which
kind of abuts again on like art objects
and Museum studies and and and those
sorts of things that that you know
taking a material culture course might
prepare you for career-wise in the
future
so this stuff makes sense to me I mean
as like political Theory I'm I mean oh
my God I'm not gonna do anything with
this but
every like it's it's sensibilities and
it's
and it's kind of I guess I can't call it
aesthetic it's it's obscenities I I
under I kind of I I already kind of move
with these kinds of ways of thinking
so that's I mean my reaction is is is
also like this battery of ideas coming
up is is something I don't have a lot of
facility with
again debauchery obscenity seduction
these these I don't know what you even
call them are they Concepts here
whatever these These deployments are are
a little bit uh strange to me now do you
mean battery as you are being battered
by them or battery as a source of energy
I mean like a battery isn't just like an
array a set a battery
good words
um yeah to to your point about his
earlier like what was it the uh the
system of objects yes so I would call
that I would still say that's him in
like a neo-marxist phase because he's
very much with Marx
pushing against it a little bit in the
same way that Deborah did and we've
talked Deborah to death but
Marx of course Drew this this
distinction between use value and
exchange value and says like the use
value is kind of being dominated by
exchange value and the commodity form
but the the system of objects is saying
that the fundamental uh opposition is
also
it's moved from I'll put it this way
it's moved from production to
consumption where consumption is the
main
determinant in
in affluent societies at least
consumption is like the the means of
class domination it doesn't mean
consuming objects but like you're
talking about collecting
there's no there's no use and exchange
value to a collection it's it's for
other reasons it's a conspicuous
consumption but I think here he's going
even further past that that we could
properly call it post Marxist I don't
know anyone who's called it that just
kind of a term that we're working with
but he he wants to just give up
the theory of history and I kind of
found it interesting when Victor was
saying he's trying to define the age
because I think he's doing the opposite
like Deborah for sure was trying to
define the age we live in the age of the
spectacle we were this and now we're
this whereas I think for for vodrar the
talking about
history and theorizing about history and
giving ages and giving we moved from
this to this and then like potentially
there's a virtual future that we move to
something else I think he's very much
given up on that and you can see that
also in his work on the symbolic
where all
societies are kind of the same in their
dealing with images and images are
always the dominant form Commodities as
a is a Marxist fantasy you could call it
to say no this is the thing that's
important this is the thing that
everyone's cared about if we could deal
with the commodity and you know the the
the means of its production I mean the
reason then that would move history and
I think that's the thing that he's
really giving up on
although I wouldn't say he's anti-marxis
because he's also very concerned with
production still but it happens to be
you know image image production yeah
production of images and signs yeah one
thing I picked up on that I I like the
yeah they seem to turn against use value
and and point out I I actually thought
this was kind of like Derita inspectors
of Marx but maybe it was beaucheryard in
um those two like early 70s texts the
mirror of production and uh the critique
of the political economy the sign he
he talks about
um
uh use value being a kind of you know
just as metaphysical let's say as as
exchange value but we rely on it because
it's connected to human need right we're
in a productive situation where we're
producing because of the use value
because it's use satisfies a human need
and so we've put the human kind of as
the metaphysical center of our
productive system
but he argues against that saying you
know use values is like a fiction of
exchange value it's something that the
that the sort of I don't know what you
call like the the marketing image the
image apparatus deployed around exchange
value kind of just creates the illusion
that it's useful or there's some kind of
underlying use of satisfying some human
need when all that's just [__] and
you can't use use value as like a
I don't know a more stable ground on
which to orient production in some
future better less capitalist society
says maybe something like that but yeah
the the focus is on use value
yeah
Bulger is critiquing the theoretical
approach to that saying you could only
have this mindset already being holy
within the order already established by
capitalism
mm-hmm and then that's why he that's why
he goes back to ancient societies and
the gift and the mouse thing
yeah sorry I shouldn't say the mouse
thing that sounds weird the mouse thing
the Disneyland no the gift exchange
because the gift economy
proceeded and is is
located also within ours but the gift
economy symbolic exchange is resistant
to that capitalist mode and there is no
use value there it's it Matt like the
material qualities of the object didn't
matter when when [__] Odysseus is
giving giving Agamemnon a a cauldron and
a tripod it's not because he's like I
needed something to cook my soup or dry
my boots thanks buddy it's a [__]
symbolic gesture to pre what perpetuate
The Exchange right yeah I was going to
say though that the reason I was getting
the impression of defining an age I
think you're right that he's not like
naming the age specifically but he does
make a lot of statements like I just
just from skimming through it quickly
like on page uh I think like 1 15
you know like this just an example he'll
be like you know it's no longer possible
to do this right it's you know you used
to be able to say something in order to
unmask its rhetoric but it's like to
denounce but we cannot say right
anything anymore and it's like he does a
lot of this thing of like we used to be
able to do this and now we can't do this
because of whatever it's all a
simulation or it's all
that's what I mean by kind of giving
these broad statements on
what is now the case and what used to
not be the case or something yeah you
get the sense that he's an academic who
hates academics and a theorist who hates
theorists yeah I feel like he's talking
to others often what he means by we is
usually theorists
because he's yeah for example saying we
have always assumed the masses to be
miserable he means theorists have
yeah it's sort of hard to see like from
what position he's speaking sometimes if
he's like parroting another point of
view or if he's actually giving his own
and the lack of any like references or
citations makes that even more difficult
and I even glanced it earlier stuff and
he yeah he does this same sort of thing
um he he quotes Kennedy saying past a
certain point in time history has not
been real and then he questions whether
that point in time ever existed so he
say history is no longer real but then
you have to go back and say but was that
point at which it became no longer real
is that point actually a point like what
what is this point now and how can we
even go back to this point and and
Discover it he kind of says the he calls
it the dead point the dead center where
every system crosses this subtle limit
of reversibility and then questions
whether this point is real or whether
it's
I don't know just some some kind of
another another useful fiction within
the within the simulated reel
yeah he says a couple things at the
beginning too about
um morality like I think he goes through
a couple things I'm actually trying to
find the pages because I thought I'd
highlighted it but um
I think he's responding to his
contemporaries and we could say this
with a lot of the
post Marxist that we've read so far
is they are they they seem to be very
still concerned with morality like
morality is his history has a moral or
even a morale it's headed somewhere we
can help it we can hinder it and the
idea that bodrive is putting forward is
like you will never get there and the
problem is not that you don't believe
hard enough the problem is that you
already believe way too much you believe
in Illusions they're not getting you're
not prepared to get rid of and so the
one of the main ones here in the section
that we read one of the main
moral
I don't know what you call it like an
injunction the moral injunction rests
upon the masses to you know overthrow
the the bourgeoisie or to move history
forward or to recognize their
immiseration I want to say
so if that's not possible
and this kind of comes back to what we
were talking about a few weeks ago in
terms of
the the masses never really do anything
unless they're very upset unless they're
starving if they if they're starving
they will do something but otherwise
they are not a force of changing history
they're not a force of mobilization as a
Marxist might see them or at least a
humanist marxists might see them they're
actually a force of inertia
yeah they stop things from happening in
society they are there as a preventative
measure to make sure things change very
slowly rather than as this this this
group of people that you can wake up to
their emisuration and will then change
society so I think that's a very uh
it's a hard pill to swallow if you're
from uh from a Mark coming from a
Marxist perspective it's what the kids
might call a black pill
um yeah I like it when he says you know
people didn't really want Revolution
they wanted a spectacle of it I think
he's quoting someone uh Rivero
um yeah and then he's like you know if
our perversion lies in this that we
never desire the real event but it's
spectacle never things but their sign
and the secret derision of their sign it
means that we don't really want things
to change the change must also seduce us
I remember liking that because it's like
that does sound kind of like a point I
mean I would never write it that way but
that does sound like a point I feel like
I've even been made in the past when
we're talking about like when we were
talking about the spectacle I think I
was saying something like uh
but the spectacle isn't the thing
exerting the force like the people are
also making it possible I think I said
something like that and that quote kind
of reminded me of it it's like we need
the things to seduce us
uh in order for them to work on us
otherwise like it's there's inertia I
think yeah and when he did reference
somebody I did look it up I tried to and
the River Roll is a French royalist 19th
century and that was about the French
Revolution what he was saying
oh right yeah yeah so he's he's actually
engaging it makes sense yeah he's
engaging with like 19th century moral
philosophers and and like whatever
sociology political economy none of that
was really separate back then we have
our disciplinary specificities today
that was alien completely alien to them
um
but yeah he was saying that about the
French Revolution can I just say too I
found it I found it amusingly
being this like corrupt Society or
something he's like uh
from like what does he say from like
Mama to the mafia
it's like talking about all Italians
like how it's like a an example of an
immoral Society living off its own
profound immorality
um
but they've accepted it they're not like
the states that has this yeah executive
streak but they're still reveling in the
profits they're not doing and they know
that there's just like a game
where everyone kind of knows that no one
really obeys the rules and they kind of
like there's kind of an Unwritten kind
of reminds me of some things would talk
about where there's kind of like
unstated rules that everyone knows and
and there's like and I guess there's
like more honesty and I will say that um
when I was in Italy not long ago I did
kind of get this sense that there was
the sun Wren I remembered specifically
when I was in the Amalfi Coast with like
the buses and there'd be like a schedule
and I kept getting empty promises about
like when the bus was coming because
they were all there standing around the
buses and I was like so when are you
gonna leave he's like oh probably
another like 10 minutes I'm like we're
there for like 20 minutes and they like
move the bus somewhere else and you're
just like and no one seems rattled about
it like the locals don't seem rattled
about it but I'm just like what is this
[__] weird game that I don't
understand what the rules are
this is that's actually really
fascinating because the unwritten rule
is that the rules don't matter right so
even if they say something then you have
to assume okay he says I'm leaving in 10
it's probably 20. it could be 30. but
beaujara talks about America in this
other
in these other terms of this it's a it's
a just a land of contradictions which
actually Echoes something Eric said last
week but this land of contradictions
where you have the greatest excesses in
Vice in something like Vegas or I don't
know New Orleans or New York in the 80s
these kind of things they're just like
the
pure excess and then at the bottom
there's still this very puritanical
sense about rules and children and
religiosity and protection and these two
things exist very happily side by side
you have one version that's Disneyland
where the kids go to hug Mickey Mouse
and then you have Vegas as the as the
flip side and these are the true
Americas despite all the rhetoric of
this religious Purity moral Purity you
know laws about what can be shown on TV
you can't imagine I can't imagine that
kind of thing happening in a in France
for example yeah the the US is an
interesting example
I've often thought that about America
just like a weird contradiction of
extreme he calls it both social and wild
he says the the true in spite of its
morality puritanism and obsession with
virtue its true motor is the objection
of free enterprise I mean that stuff I
guess the point is that stuff you know
runs on immorality as opposed to
morality
I think I think the the old school way
we were talking about of regarding let's
say the masses is that they are morally
deprived they are there they they are
the source of immorality in any society
and they must be educated out of their
best deal immoral
existence and so these you know these
some of the people he's citing are are
you know they're discussing things like
charity schools and and and and doing
things for the betterment of the lower
classes this sort of magnanimous
aristocratic charity and they're arguing
about whether or not it's going to have
a good effect and some of them say yeah
of course like getting get it you know
that their moral virtue contributes to
the overall society and other people are
saying no because if you teach them
morality they actually become you know
if you teach them they become more
materialistic like the upper classes and
we don't want to have too many
materialistic people because we can't
support that the schools will become too
expensive and we'll have to shut them
all down and it'll ultimately be a drain
on society so let's just leave them in
their fallen State I mean like those are
the kinds of [__] arguments in these
sociologists are or whatever these
political economists are having in the
19th and 18th century
and he's keyed into this stuff because
he's a social theorist although he
probably can't use the term social as of
this text at least
he's a theorist of some kind
but that fundamental kind of
immoral energy
I mean I guess backing up one of my
overall takes is the victory of of the
object
over the subject the object is now sort
of getting its revenge it's turning on
the subject it's absorbed instead of you
know the subjects having Mastery and
understanding of the object the object
is actually completely dominating it's
the the seduction the um
I guess the evil Genie or the object the
irony of passion these terms he's using
is is that reversal of the object where
we think we've we've dominated it we've
absorbed it into our conceptual
Frameworks and lo and behold we really
haven't we're actually the stooge of the
strategy that the odd the objects like
running a game on us yeah this is kind
of the point of the text and we're
getting into the heart of it now is as
as academics you know especially Eric
you and I we've both probably said this
before but don't don't don't succumb to
the subject object Duality right that's
a bad Duality to fall into don't
privilege the subject
and then we kind of go yeah but the
object's there to bojrar goes further
than that and that's this is what he
calls evil is to join sides against
subjectivity which is really in a sense
to join sides against all of Western
philosophy so this is a dump on Western
philosophy in general
is to say no I'm going to take the
immoral side I'm going to take the evil
side and this is what seduction is I
think he's got a book with seduction in
the title but anyway seduction is the
power of the object to play
this shell game with subjects so that
the subjects think that they're in
control and really what he means by
subjects is theorists
dearest to
whether whether you're a New York Times
theorist or a philosophy
School theorist it doesn't matter to him
it's like even a scientist in that too
even a scientist yeah the object always
appears where the scientist expects but
in in terms of morality and evil he he
kind of recalls manichaeanism or
gnosticism by saying we've always
believed the world to be at bottom
rational from the Christian Perspective
which is the scientific perspective
which is the metaphysical perspective
and instead
we should think of the world as
succumbing to the things that we believe
about it over and over and over again
in order to trick us into this lulled
state of certainty or lulled state of
domination where we are in control you
know if you take that at face value
alone it's kind of an absurd thing to
say but if you take it from the
perspective of someone who's really
becoming anti
the theory perspective or anti-academic
then he's saying you can continue
sitting there publishing your books
going to your conferences writing about
how much you know
and in the end what you know and what
you don't know doesn't matter because
whatever is going to happen is going to
happen anyway
it doesn't matter how many pamphlets you
publish
so he says um we're gonna take the
prince we're going to take the side of
evil or he is at least he's I'm gonna go
take the side of evil if you're gonna
make a duality
I'll take the evil side because it's
more fun
and he goes on to say that like before
whatever you want to call the Western
tradition primitive people didn't see it
in any differently than that they didn't
trust their gods they didn't believe
that their gods were really in the know
they invented them so that they could
put them to death
and he kind of gets onto a primal human
urge here the reason that we even have
Politics the reason we have parties
voting political systems or even before
that Kings and Lords is so that we have
someone to adipolize again someone that
we can just hate
and that is the seduction
of the uh the the person in power the
seduction is to believe oh they they are
supporting me and worshiping me and
voting for me so I'm gonna believe that
I I do have that power and that would be
an example of that seduction is to
believe what the masses give you when
the masses aren't really giving you
anything they're going to do the lowest
common effort they're an inertial force
not a historical Force yeah and even
even history itself he says the way
history moves progress doesn't come from
morality and value it comes from
immorality and vice hence the evil Genie
the evil Genie
behind it all is immorality and vice
it's this dark energy that drives
forwards actually scientific progress
and moral reasoning and and construction
of value systems and it and our own even
our own you know writing our histories
under coming to understand ourselves and
I guess in a maybe like a collective
objective sense it's actually immorality
that drives that forward this this
deeper energy he talks about is
I mean I guess there's some
interchangeable closely related terms
yeah it's the genie immorality Vice
debauchery you know all these all these
ideas like he's he's zoning in on this
this sort of immoral absent core that
drives all these sort of positive things
forward and we forget about that immoral
core or preferred I don't know how to go
forward with that one he just we prefer
not to look at it or to deny that it
exists and we we kind of persecute
people like one of his points of
bringing up manicianism manichaeism is
is that you know it's one of those
movements in history that have positive
that like reality is evil it's it's or
reality is an illusion and there's
something some evil Genie or evil deity
behind it all kind of fooling us
tricking us into thinking that
appearances are
verifiable and and real
when really no but those those kinds of
people tend to get you know called
Heretics or or
dismissed and persecuted but he's he's
fully taking on like yeah like you said
pills he's fully sort of gonna
take on this this cynical view of of
society which looks at that and he says
this view itself is not immoral and
that's the point it's like almost like
ignoring that immorality advice
I mean it makes sense to me in a way
right Vice is just self-serving behavior
and what do we do what is capital
capital runs on that right we we go out
we buy [__] right for ourselves we're
not buying [__] for the betterment of
society
although you know after big disasters
when we get encouraged to go out and
purchase that's what it seems to be but
really the main movement is is
immorality yeah go to the mall
don't stop buying it's a profoundly
anti-haggle this is like the the most
devastating assault on Hegel on all
fronts that Hegel is on the side of God
and boduard is saying well if you're a
God then I will take the side of the
devil yeah like it makes so much sense
to me like competition like he brings a
competition is is the new morality and
competition is actually immoral but it's
moral to uh like in a way it would be
immoral to
you know take competition away hence
like antitrust laws
and we we seek competition we seek a
fair playing field so let's say through
that those kinds of laws and yet
competition is not moral people aren't
making you know this is this isn't
gentlemen's War where there's these
kinds of rules of conduct competition is
is what it is it has to be competitive
it can't be half-assed same with fashion
same with all these other I don't know
why he brings up Glory but fashion
gambling I was complaining about
gambling apps gambling is better than
work and gambling is immoral and yet we
you know we gambling addiction we're
always going on about and yet gambling
is a humongous
stimulus to the economy holy [__] and
pornography of course pornography is the
new Beauty and pornography is immoral
whereas in so let's say in Kant beauty
is the symbol of the true
yeah but he's saying this is actually a
more objective view because he's taking
into account I presume the the that
reversibility of the object just when we
think we've got it it it's not there
it's it's somewhere else tricking us
into
moving forward with our experiments and
our investigations and our Pursuits and
our desires wait doesn't he call this
section ironical strategies is that
right so what does he mean by that
ironically I gotta admit I have I've
tried to figure that out several times
and the only thing I can think of is
irony is the displacement of meaning
from the text right
I mean not just textual irony but
there's there's more meaning than what
you're saying in a in an in an act of
verbal irony or a context
so the only thing that I'm thinking that
can mean is that there is a scene
where what you say happens plays out
like we live in a democracy we live in a
Democratic Society it's a great example
but the the meaning of it is elsewhere
the meaning of it is in death and not an
inequality and exporting misery and
yeah like Eric said our morality gives
way and it's fueled actually by the
energies of immorality
so it's not a strategy to overcome
anything it's a strategy to be more
objective and objective meaning taking
the object's side but also objective as
being more realistic this is real this
is what actually happens despite what
any no offense Democratic theorists says
on the surface is what's happening we
can just look and know that the meaning
is elsewhere and this is also in place
when he talks about uh polling polling
like democracy just runs on polls
everyone watches the polls the people
that vote watch the polls so that they
know what to believe than the people
that are ostensibly in power for their
term they watch the polls so they know
what to do so there's nothing that ever
happens because the people that don't
know what to believe watch polls in
order to believe something and then the
people that are in power just respond to
those
polls as images objects
so no one nothing ever happens and you
can see this in his favorite place in
the world America
because
what you who you vote for doesn't make a
[__] of difference
even if you vote for the guy that you
want to win if he wins he can't do
anything after that because the powers
elsewhere in the obscene in the death in
the in war in Invasions illegal
invasions in gambling in the drug
industry so I think that's what it means
by ironic is that the
we become obscene obscene so just means
against the scene and he's saying that
we still live in this massive scene of
where we live the theorists believe that
that specifically people who are paid to
think about this they believe that this
is what it is then Trump shows up and
he's obscene and everyone loses their
mind like the system's collapsing when
for him the system has already collapsed
it collapsed long before trump it
collapsed he's writing what is this 1983
something like that it collapsed a long
ass time ago and it was the meaning
system that collapsed so the irony for
him is to just say to displace the
meaning of his words as as a theorist
and say I'm going to just be the
theorist that
do you think that um oh yeah so like
earlier and I think it's implied here
kind of I mean the reason I was hearing
your voice when I was reading this is
because I do think there's this kind of
ideas don't matter uh kind of uh subtext
here not even just subtext but I think
in some sense
blatant over text yeah exactly overt but
I suppose I wondered like I kind of want
to challenge you pills on this and just
say like do you really believe that
because I think you know not to litigate
the the the episode we did on the whole
zizak article but like you were very
heated and and it seemed like it
mattered right like what jajek was
writing about trans people
and like certain ideas that float around
like so I guess do you think do you
think there might be a contradiction
there for you at least in
in
um like how far this thesis can go that
it can all just be reduced
no I was I was objecting to Zizek
believing that his ideas mattered more
than any other consideration at that
time
I think the considerations particular as
they are are far more important than any
idea about those specific ideas
yeah and in a way he's saying here in an
ironical sense that that ideas are all
that matter right right nobody cares
about
what is what does he say here like how
do our rational and program societies
how do our supposedly rational Society
how do they function you know what makes
them work
is it is it is it scientific progress
and objective information and Collective
happiness and understanding of facts and
causes and proper punishment for the
guilty all that he says no what
fascinates everyone is the debauchery of
signs that reality is everywhere and
always to botched by sides and when we
go watch debates when we get into the
public forum and we we we
you know get into these idea conflicts
with people like that's that's the
spectacle there that's what like so in a
way all people care about our ideas in
terms in in so far as it's it's a
simulated kind of you know truth truth
procedure we're simulating we're we're
simulating arguments and we're
simulating getting to the truth we're
we're sort of falling into this
I mean he didn't say a whole lot about
it in this chapter but I assume that's
what the kind of ecstasy is it's like
The Passion of the subject for the
object kind of like um
I guess in ecstasy meaning sort of
standing outside you know we have this
passion this almost like in the
religious sense like The Passion of
Christ where we where we throw off
ourselves and we we try to meet the
object naked as it is and so then the
the Ecstasy of the social becomes the
masses the Ecstasy of sex becomes
whatever porn the Ecstasy of which it
ends up having like that's being the
more real than real right the Ecstasy of
ideas I have to interject with this but
the the reality of the economy being
gambling he wrote this in 83. before
crypto before speculative assets before
the tech bubbles
I think that's extremely profound and
exactly on point oh even appalling [__]
too right remember like was it in the
90s was it like the Bill Clinton and
Tony Blair administrations they had
hired these these campaign managers who
ran pretty much totally on polls like
they like polling became so important in
politics and it resulted in these huge
catastrophes like that enormous God I'm
forgetting my history but that huge
train disaster in Britain as a result of
these like poll governments who who can
only Opera I mean and this is how
[__] Hollywood operates too right
focus groups right how do I make a good
movie well I gotta show it to focus
groups and I gotta Paul people and I
gotta get opinions about things like I
think that stuff is very prophetic too
about the polls but yeah sorry I I cut
you off there I was excited
no I like it that's good
we believe in it too much still even
still and that's why he's saying you
know all of this is going to crash in
disaster it's going to be fatal so I am
going to be instead of a theorist who
changes anything I'm gonna be a fatal
theorist I'm going to hold Theory
hostage I'm going to be a theoretical
terrorist all of his fun little quips
because I know that it's already done
and I know in the end that the object
wins people don't win humans are not
going to win the proletariat is not
going to overthrow the bourgeoisie so
he'd rather make a more interesting
object with his theory yeah exactly so
he says he even says that he says that
explicitation he says that explicitly at
the end of this chapter
even if for no other reason that it's
more interesting to do Theory this way
we should do Theory this way
instead of being correct instead of
being right instead of being the most
radical and I think he says the word
radical like a whole bunch of times in
here but the most radical position is
just to say
ideas don't matter
and to be the theorists the Champion's
idea is not mattering so maybe that's
where I found some that's interesting
profound sympathy debauchery of ideas is
more powerful than reality right well
that's what I was going to say is like I
think it's not so much that ideas don't
matter I mean I think Eric was saying in
a way it's it's only ideas that matter
because it's all part of this like
it's more real than real exactly it's
what makes the spectacle like the
seductive thing that you want to
participate in true or using we're using
ideas in two ways here though right yeah
because the flip side or yeah one is
ideas Drive Society history we need to
have a reasonable discourse of ideas and
the other one is saying no the exchanges
of language are the only thing that
matters which frees you to do anything
you don't have to be on the right side
of History if there is no history you
can say whatever you want for effect you
can it only matter whatever works in
fact history always moves by the wrong
side yeah well it's not even whatever
works it's what's the most seductive
what's the most fascinating
that's a criteria of like what works I
guess maybe
like what's fascinating but what's gonna
actually get
kind of um currency within the
simulation right the seductive
simulation
that's what I mean by effective right
it's like what's gonna have the most oh
yeah what communication reproduces
itself the most exactly that's it that
would be like the reason that's the
reason JiJi got famous in the first
place and the reason that we all liked
him
right and and the right too right like
he's this isn't all working for the best
too right Jordan Peterson got famous in
the same space which is this sort of
postmodern media space right post 1960s
I mean it's hard to deny we haven't been
alive long enough to have seen all the
changes but I mean it's it's hard to
deny that I mean this seems almost like
a very kind of updated version of when
we did leotard too right on the
post-modern condition because he's
talking about the same thing scientific
advances in technology have pushed us
into this new condition and especially
the the sort of commercialization and
miniaturization of these Technologies
which are first deployed in war and then
they become commercialized and consumer
items and these things are pushing us
into a new like cultural condition okay
uh and and that condition is a
proliferation of you know images and
relaying messages and and copying copies
and mass proliferation of just you know
objects of things you can think about
right that's that's the situation and
and this is
I don't want to say it's descriptive of
it because it's like that's not reality
but it's the Ecstasy if the real it's
the real standing outside itself as
simulation
and the hyperreal
which is more real than real and we
don't really want or know or care if
there was a real that it's replaced
because
how do we even go back to that point
from within the hyper reel we don't do
it we
I want to go back to Jordan Peterson a
second because there there we go into
the
the ethical
question which I would not believe in
there's not an ethical question to to
Jordan Peterson
but the common response to Jordan
Peterson is
he his audience is a bunch of
you know dumb dumb 20 year olds we've
said that on this podcast literally
before they are dumb
and if there's not an answer to if
there's an answer to Jordan Peterson
it's not to read his books and to
dissect his lectures and to point out
where he's wrong because nobody cares
whether or not he's right or wrong
people don't follow him because he's
right it's impossible for anyone to
follow someone because they're correct
in this day and age if we're taking
Boatyard seriously so the reason that
sorry the reason that Jordan Peterson
would have so so much success in this
environment in the simulated history
that's not real history anymore is
because there's no one else fascinating
so this would be a failure of
the academic Cloister types the the
explainer types the people who are going
to put each one of Jordan Peterson's
claims on the pedestal of reason and
decide whether or right he's or whether
or not he's wrong what he's correct
about when he made a false statement
when he made a misleading statement
that's all wrong
you can't do it that way you have to be
fascinating you have to out Fascinate if
there's something that you disagree with
but I agree with that you can't fall
back onto some sort of morality and say
Jordan Peterson is bad because he's
immoral because we're past that
he even says that about the Revolution
and change right we don't want change
change has to seduce us exactly right
revolution has to be seductive and and
the problem with that is it can work
either way it can be a revolution or it
can be a d Evolution it doesn't it
doesn't necessarily go the way we want
it to it's just something you know until
that point until we're absorbed in some
kind of fascination with some new trend
and we're willing to change
again that's us being seduced by
something out there some some objects
some or some I guess object in a very
like broad sense
the object is the world but doesn't this
make so much sense of why
like Joe Rogan is the most popular
podcaster he is just the most mid
neutral I'm not sure if I believe that
does he ever ask why not really doesn't
go into depth in anything he's the most
neutral
speak for the masses that he's the
object of the object masses guy you can
actually find and also the most pod most
popular podcaster that exists and
everyone you can call him stupid all you
want it doesn't matter it doesn't make a
difference no one cares whether he's
stupid yeah no one's listening him
listening to him to change anything
no I agree I mean I think I think I this
makes sense to me I agree like the whole
point about things being seductive like
it does frustrate me when you know on
Jordan Peterson people just want to
focus on how wrong he is about certain
things that he says as opposed to trying
to ask the question of like well why is
he seductive why do people like him what
is it that he's capturing right and I
think that's where you can have
interesting conversations about the way
the culture is talking to young men
right that there's like a failure
because it's seducing young men I think
I agree with that kind of framing but I
think by the way I need to correct we're
using seduction in the wrong way there
you fascinating is what you probably
want to say fascinating yeah okay
because seduction has a specific
definition right okay okay
sorry for being the language no no
that's okay that's okay does he mean
seductive because he because he also
talks about how Revolution needs to be
seductive so
what's the difference there it's more
like it maybe from it's a perspectival
thing Fascination seduction draws you in
fact seduction is the power of the
object yeah okay which is the power of
the world
whereas the fascination is the power of
the image
okay so you're saying that for for
you're saying that for Jordan Peterson
as an image it's fascinating so
fascinates you and it pulls you in but
as opposed okay because beaudread wants
to take the side of Seduction I guess I
guess the uh the object there might be
sort of like what what are his common
themes whatever like masculinity might
be like one of those things that's sort
of the an object we're thinking of the
individual the sanctity of the
individual yeah those those things would
be the objects exerting a seductive
Force and and and and and you know
Jordan Peterson the uh the the sort of
Silver Fox with his nice suit standing
there that would be like the fascinating
image of the man kind of thing right
yeah so I I I I I agree with that
account I think it for me where I don't
know if this is actually in beaudryard
or if this is just kind of the way pills
expresses his agreement with beauchard
but I I sometimes think that
um there's maybe an overly discounting
the real effect that these images can
have in the world and that like so
because I think sometimes I hear you
pill as a kind of saying like great
celebrating like I don't need to care
about anything because like it's all
images it doesn't matter it's all
[__]
and while I kind of agree in the way
like in framing things in this way as
are they fascinating are they seductive
right I think that's a good way of
framing it as opposed to
kind of foregrounding instead of
foregrounding this kind of rational
morality foregrounding seduction
Fascination makes more sense to me
but I also think that what's being
forgotten here is the actual material
impact that
one thing taking like all the air time
can have and again going back to our
episode our controversial episode you
know on g-shek and and the trans issue
look I think that like the the hysteria
around trans people right now is having
a material impact right on people's
lives there's laws being passed because
of [__] crazy people like Christopher
rufo or Jordan Peterson or you know
whatever and I think a lot of people
objected to jajek talking about that
because he's kind of
putting his he's dipping his toe into
that large kind of cycle of Hysteria
so like yes we can frame it this way but
can we just be like I don't need to care
about anything anymore no I don't think
that that follows in my opinion when you
take uh when you have recourse to
material
uh and and effects and you get you like
he has this section on cause and effect
right and and he's I mean on the one
hand he's trying to kind of do the um
do the do the leclaude and move thing
and and eliminate determinism from the
picture
determinism like when you look for
determinants like say determinants of
social welfare or whatever right like
what are the determinants of that you
look at for those things and then you
say okay these are the causes these are
the causes and the effect is the you
know what people experience and I in a
way he's trying to break down that cause
effect determination determinated thing
that that that opposition
so I I mean I don't yeah the recourse to
the material
is kind of going back to a Marxist
framework that he does well okay move
for a little bit like you know so let me
let me rephrase them let's say let me
rephrase in terms of material like
like okay so laws like if you're a trans
person and laws are changing so that you
can't get medication I don't know what
to call that other than a material
effect in the world
that's a good point and it's the common
view you know Jordan Peterson and Matt
Walsh are making people transphobic but
but
here that is confusing the cause for the
effect because if Jordan Peterson were
not transphobic he would not have a
platform that is his platform from his
first YouTube video and his platform
is not his
his position or any politician's
position is already that of the mass and
the mass is you know at a general
largely unconcerned level transphobic
precisely because it is a change and the
mass resists change and maybe this is a
good example the mass
25 years ago was homophobic and probably
still is but you know hear me out at
least you put Will and Grace on TV you
put gay characters on TV a bunch of
celebrities come out as gay that is what
does the seduction and the seduction is
actually what changes anything so in
simulation the media change happens
first it's not a change based on
rationality it's not a change based on
morality
like it's not like Obama legislated
about gay marriage because it was the
right thing to do he did it because it
was popular it was the popular thing to
do and it was popular because of that
seduction of the image not because it
was morally
correct
so you don't argue the mass into
changing it's something that has to be
seduced I think I think it would be the
way you analyze them like you know
people are talk talk about you know what
cause like that most recent shooting
right everybody's waiting about because
we've heard a little bit about this like
recent shooter might be trans and we're
waiting what were the motives behind
this thing they've done is it is it
trans issues or is it something
unrelated you know we're waiting for the
cause of of the of every shooting we're
waiting for them to come out and
determine the cause and he's saying that
doesn't matter because we're getting
this stuff from the media we're getting
this this is all part of the simulation
we're simulating an investigation and
we're simulating the resolution and we
all go away with a good understanding
our minds are now clear because we know
what caused this last horrific incident
I think he's just trying to get away
from that right like he's he's he's
taking he's like spectacle 2.0 here
there's no there's no economic
determining factors Behind these things
and in the individualist language
there's no causal motive making people
do things like this right you're you're
seduced by some kind of world view
you're seduced by some
you know array of signs and signifiers
that point to whatever immigrants are
the problem
Target some latinx Community you become
seduced by these things so then how do
you talk about causation
when you're being drawn in
when these events are being simulated
before us on the media
you know when we watch like a a Sherlock
Holmes movie or read a book you know
we're so titillated and and
we the the Ecstasy of solving the
problem right and that big explanation
at the end Sherlock always does right of
how everything went down and what led to
what and cause and effects leading to
this nice bow being tied on the whole
situation which it reminds me of what
the way like g-jac talks about film Noir
right like that the the end requires the
death of the subject it requires the
death of the main character usually
whoever it is like the the main
detective usually drawn in by the Femme
Fatale right the femininity of the
object right which again we're not
saying femininity is tied to biological
factors that's that's another problem
because when we say biology causes
people to be feminine now but again it's
this this new way he's trying to
articulate and and so I [__] that's
probably so unclear but yeah like I
think cause and effect falls out of that
we're getting away from determination in
a way I don't know if if any of that
made sense you can respond to it so
you're saying that nothing has you're so
you're saying that nothing has a cause
or effect on this video that's not true
at all I think there's a self there's a
self movement right it's it is hegelian
in that sense and that there is a self
movement of the objects it's not cause
and effects
self movement and it's this evil core
that moves it whether the object is the
economy whether the object is the social
which we don't believe in anymore with
Beaudry art here we don't believe in it
the social is is a self-moving force
it's like its own cause
right and and and its appearance is
predicated on its disappearance like its
effects precedes the Cause right like
remember that that part about sacrifice
what he's he's talking about politics
and the way politicians have to like
nobody wants power right everybody like
the true the the people who are in the
know they don't want the power because
the person who is the image of power the
Big Brother figure is the sacrificial
lamb right it's it reminds me I just
read uh like Oedipus again and um
[__] what's his name crisis the the king
the the other king who well not not
Oedipus Oedipus is the king of Thebes
and the other guy uh you know he says I
want Oedipus wants to leave
and the other guy says I don't want
Power because power leads to these
issues right he know he he's a smart
politician you know he doesn't want to
be the in the place of power we're
always struggling not like when you're
trying to maintain power the struggle is
to not be in the space of power you have
to be outside of it
kind of thing like the figure could be
the Iraq War here we want or or any War
right and since the since the 1960s you
blame the president for the war
the president is the evil one it doesn't
focus on any of the benefits of the war
the economic benefits it doesn't focus
on all the people who got rich off the
war it doesn't focus on all of the
crimes that were peripheral to the war
it wasn't focusing on the media who
perpetuated lies about the war in order
to make it happen you just blame bush
bush is like exempt from from any
criticisms
except for words he's not responsible in
any way for it so the political the
power takes the fall and everybody and
the system keeps moving in exactly the
way that it was moving already we need a
new war we need a new export Market
I did have the the Mandeville uh stuff
right where where he's getting this idea
of of the the evil the evil Genie and
and he's he's he cites Mandeville twice
which I take to mean that this is
incredibly important because he doesn't
cite much
um Bernard Mandeville is a is a uh
late 17th early 18th century philosopher
he says um I feel like I have
demonstrated here this is Mandeville
saying that neither the friendly
qualities and kind affections that are
natural to man nor the real virtues he
is capable of acquiring by reason and
self-denial that is denial of our our
our
urges or or
neither by virtues or or by friendly
qualities
um neither of these things are the
foundations of society but what we call
evil in the world moral as well as
natural evil is the grand principle that
makes us sociable creatures the solid
basis the life and support of all trades
and employment without exception that
there that there we must look for the
truth the true origin of all Arts and
Sciences and the moment evil ceases the
society must be spoiled if not totally
dissolved and this is a thesis he's put
forward here right that the that that
capitalism this early form of
circulation that he's talking about is
it runs on Vice which he defines against
virtue virtue is acting in the interests
of other people Vice is acting in the
self-interest that's a sort of simple
thing and it's called the Fable of the
bees or private vices public benefits
that's the subtitle and he argues that
that you know our private vices when you
go out and you buy things for yourself
you employ whatever Bakers prostitutes
Smiths whatever then those people employ
other people to renew their trades etc
etc he says Society runs on Vice and if
you eliminate the evil you eliminate
what holds Society together and he got
into major disputes one of them with you
know Adam Smith right because Adam Smith
believed that we could have virtuous you
know consumption
and and others also hated his like
Bishop Berkeley attacked him too for his
theory of immorality uh being the core
of society that's why he's referencing
him here that I think that's part of
where this whole idea comes from is this
theory that that Society runs on Vice
and evil and I mean this guy's theory is
that he quote private vices by the
dexterous management of a skillful
politician may be turned into public
benefits end quote but suggesting that
if we try to educate the masses with as
I was saying earlier with the intention
of removing you know these setting up
these charity schools and getting rid of
their moral imperfections that are
corrupting our our uh our our Arnold
style you know sweetness and light
culture is the best of everyone's
thought and done kind of society if we
try to educate them out of that you know
something people think okay that's good
but he's saying here you know no that's
what we run on this right we run Society
runs on evil the moment evil ceases
Society is spoiled if not totally
dissolved
but he doesn't stop there right that
you're speaking strictly about
capitalism
and he's saying this goes back to
Western philosophy
back to Plato that the real is rational
and we are facing the return of the
irrational which is evil
you know according to
even Plato the the material or at least
the manichaeanism interpretation of
Plato Plato and we're facing the return
of evil
because the evil has always been there
and the evil has always been the engine
and the matter the matter that is
blocking our view of the good has always
been
full of energy as opposed to the
theorists ideas that lack energy there
are wisps they are simulated from the
beginning so
if he's he's he he brings this up
several times we're setting up for a
battle of the end times and if you're
any kind of theorist this might be a
good way to conclude if you're any type
of theorist then you have to decide will
you be on the side of the sheep or will
you be on the side of the goats
because we're gonna face we're gonna
have a face down with reality where with
the return of the object and if you are
the type of person that thinks that
reality is real it's subject to the
capacities of Reason subject to the
capacities of our ability to know and
make sense of then you're going to be in
for a rude awakening so he's saying I'm
just gonna skip to the end I'm gonna
take the side of the evil Genie I'm
going to take the side of
matter of the world of the direction
that everything's already going
he's drawing a dividing line between
himself and basically everyone else in
terms of
not just capitalism especially
capitalism but especially the the
history of philosophy and the history of
History saying we got it wrong and we're
about ready for our rude awakening for
having got it wrong
yeah he says a lot of stuff I was going
to bring up just at the end his dunks on
the masses that like I know probably oh
can you read that that's my favorite
part there's a couple I don't know he
says a couple times I mean at one point
he says the best example uh well he's
talking about something before that but
he's saying the best example of this is
the masses they are not at all an object
of Oppression or manipulation the masses
do not have to be liberated and in any
case they cannot be all their
trans-political powers in being
there as pure object that is to say in
opposing their silence and their absence
of Desire against any political wish to
make them speak
um and there's more stuff I mean I don't
know if that was this the section you
were thinking of
talks about like the stupefying power of
the mass as object the masses incarnate
the pure object of the political
um the ideal of an absolute power I was
looking for the part when he says we we
theorists
we've always figured out the masses
we've known them we knew that they were
oppressed we knew that they were
immiserated we psychoanalysts knew that
they were like under the burden of the
father
but maybe they weren't ever like that
maybe they had they always knew their
power they always didn't give a [__] and
this just kind of brings back
to
the way that you know when you talk to a
normal person about philosophy they
don't feel exactly they don't feel like
you're right about them you feel like
you're right about them because you've
read read marks or or red Freud and you
go yeah I know you but from the outside
so part of the return of the object or
the Revenge of the object is proving
they're not caring was more true than
you're theorizing about them not caring
they always knew what they were I like
the part when he's talking also just
about the masses as like there's like I
took it to be that there's a traditional
theory that you have you know some
Authority at the top that like rules the
masses and and I think you know they he
kind of reverses it right and he's like
the masses
um you know he's like it's no longer
power that pulls the masses and it's
awake it's the masses that drag power
down to its fault which sounds
optimistic but it's actually but it's
actually not in a way it's it's like
that the power in a way it's implying
that the power that we have right now
that we complain about it's like the
masses want it in a way it's like this
is extremely anti-anarchist is yeah they
want it there and they don't want it
there because they're stupid they want
it there so they have someone to blame
and if it comes to it they have someone
to kill
exactly they don't want to be running
around looking for who to kill they want
to they want to know him see him he's up
there when [__] goes down that's who we
kill
yeah I mean I was also going to say
quickly that I think what's interesting
about this is it sounds like I mean he's
saying a lot of things that
um kind of more right-leaning like
liberals and Libertarians say about the
masses right I mean it does it has this
kind of like I mean I know it's not but
it has this kind of feel like I feel
like a lot of right-wing libertarian
types
who just kind of want to reduce human
beings to like rational actors which of
course beaudryard isn't doing but
there's a sense in which there is a this
realism you guys were talking about it
as a kind of realism and I think at one
point even quotes Machiavelli right at
one point
um and it's true I've actually been
grading essays on Machiavelli's The
Prince and I at the same time that I was
reading this and I was like oh wow there
is actually a lot of overlap because for
Machiavelli the whole thing is like the
public is fickle their their desirous
they get bored they need to be
entertained right they need to be shown
the way and that's why it's okay for you
to do amoral things because
insofar as it works to stupefy these
fickle masses who don't know what they
want who just want someone over them to
tell them what to do but like you also
can't you know be too tyrannical because
then they'll turn against you right like
you were saying they want someone to
blame it's like very similar to
Machiavelli and realism they also want
someone fun right yes exactly they want
Donald Trump they do not want Hillary
Clinton well this is exactly this fits
perfectly with Machiavelli's conception
of virtue right it's like The Virtue
like in the sense of Machiavellian sense
is a leader who is this political
Craftsman which does not mean virtue in
the moralist sense it means virtue and
being like a a tactician and part of
that tactician is being entertaining
having a it's all about the politics of
appearance right it's all about how do
you seem to the masses are you fitting
in with what they want and right and
like if you if you're really good at it
then you have this kind of Machiavellian
virtue but it's the kind of old moralist
idea is irrelevant for that so yeah I
mean it's interesting to just read this
um because most of the left Theory I
feel like we read
um kind of wants to turn its back on
that kind of realism talk about you know
and even I was I was I was having a
really good conversations with some
people in the in our Discord actually
and you know one of the things that kind
of came up is this classic thing it's
like you know people always want to say
that the public is stupid but like you
know they they know what they want and
they want to mobilize and it's like
there's that classic line I feel like in
some leftist circles and bow direct is
definitely coming hard against that he
was definitely more his his language
style his writing style was definitely
more of because his teacher was already
LeFevre right he was much more Marxist
sounding before whereas this sounds much
more nichien sounding yeah he has a
LeFevre to Nietzsche split and now the
critique is no longer an a historical
morale
so how do I say that historical morality
critique it's more of an aristocratic
critique yeah I've heard that yeah the
increasing influence of of nichon is
later works because yeah some of these
ideas like reversibility are building on
Niche and Concepts I like like you know
his jokes right like the the best kinds
of jokes are are reversible are about
reversibility like the uh the you know
the the psychologist and the rat and the
rat tells us that that he's perfectly
conditioned the psychologist to give him
a piece of cheese every time he pushes
the button yeah exactly I mean that goes
into a lot that's like a form of a lot
of stuff here right like a being a
social theorist thinking about political
economy a lot of the time your object is
is the public
and the public reverses into the masses
which has this inertia right like it's
it it's always resisting sort of change
and movement
inertia the mass appears
as something that doesn't want change
doesn't want things thrust upon them the
masses being the pure object
that has vanished from The Horizon of
the subjects as he puts it at one point
yeah pure objects again being like the
ex Ecstasy of the social
where you know the passion of the person
to throw off their subjectivity and
encounter the object well there you have
it you have the pure object of the
social
which are the masses and they're the the
the object again performs a reversal
he said the masses know they're
powerless and they don't want power we
reproach them for these signs of
stupidity and passivity but but they're
not that at all he says yeah I'm reading
this this is a good part right that's
the they're very snobbish they're very
snobbish they're snobbish yeah they're
Discerning maybe a very Discerning about
and they want to delegate they want to
delegate their choice to someone else to
something else and they're snobbish
about that and what makes them happy is
kind of like knowing that someone else
has it worse or that it could be worse
for them so I was thinking about this in
terms of you know put your finger down
on any leftist publication or leftist
commentator right put your finger down
anywhere
they'll definitely say things correctly
like oh in 1950s America you could you
could work at a gas station and support
your family while your wife stays home
and raises three kids and you would buy
a house for for 30
twenty ten thousand dollars you'd own
your own house on a gas station and
attend an employee and that doesn't
change that doesn't interest people that
doesn't Fascinate people what fascinates
people is there's immigrants coming here
to take your jobs not you could have had
it better and in this very country that
you live in your grandparents had it
much better than you did but rather the
fascination that you're gonna lose what
little you do have is far more
interesting than a story about how
government legislation could change to
bring back your your grandparents or
parents quality of life
and you know speaking for the masses and
what they want is is what theorists are
trying to do all right trying to
understand their objects grasp it and
and then speak for them and and we then
we talk about how they're alienated or
how they're repressed and human marxists
think they're alienated and then we get
into the whole subject object dialectic
which he wants to leave behind right or
we talk about oh they're repressed and
they have these unconscious desires that
and that in order to
part of a functioning Associates we have
to repress those desires and they come
out and
you know anti-social ways we have to
curb them into creative and and
productive Outlets instead right these
are all ways of trying to find out what
is wrong with the masses we assume
they're stupid and there's something
wrong with them find out what's wrong
with them they're alienated from the
objects they're repressed in their
psyches and that we try to figure out
what to do to make them better yeah
they're they're pushed they're pushed by
capitalist ideology yeah I mean this is
like a black pill that I agree with on
uh like for the most part in Boatyard
yeah I love it like right above the
quote you're reading earlier too Eric
he's like not only do people surely not
want to be told what they want but they
don't even want to know it and it's not
even certain that they want to want
yeah and I was thinking of uh which
Which movie was it one of those new
um
um uh Jordan peel movies
where the the white girlfriend is
sitting in the car with the black
boyfriend and the cop pulls them over
and she starts speaking for him and
defending him and make and and the guy
is saying you know stop stop stop this
is not helping and she's like no you
shouldn't accept this this isn't what
you like kind of deserve right and she
starts speaking for him and telling the
cop off and and this is causing a whole
you know well this is one of a major
attention builder in the movie but uh I
think it's also you know there's another
version of what he's talking about right
all right kind of the theater she
becomes the theorist of the masses she
becomes the theorist of race she becomes
the theorist of Oppression and she
starts talking for the oppressed object
of her investigation to the authorities
she intercedes on their behalf and it's
like the again
that's not what is required here that's
not what is wanted that's something else
and we don't know what that is except
for these fatal strategies which are to
adopt the strategies of the object which
performs these reversals and and and
regresses her or um or or pulls together
in these fronts of of um of inertia
and non-movement because what do we need
we always need Movement we need growth
we need we need
you know
capitalism requires this
we need to become more obscene
the theorists need to become less
academic less cloistered less talking
down their nose and they need to become
more obscene more informatic
this way of describing
I find myself convinced by broadly but I
don't agree with the thesis that I'm not
even sure bojrat is making it's more
like a pillows thesis that well then we
don't need to care about any of this
stuff because it doesn't matter anyway
like I'm not convinced by that because I
still think that there's a way of
talking about the effect that the the
simulation and the spectacle is having
that that has like real import to people
and there's a wave and I think actually
if anything
um looking at things from this
perspective
can then in can then also help in
understanding okay if you want to push
for something you need to stop you know
with this rational argumentation you
just need to make it more fascinating
right and it's like so like in a way it
doesn't mean that you shouldn't care
about stuff and you shouldn't fight for
things but it does maybe tell you about
how you should be doing those things
because understanding what's actually
like taking up space
um and the reasons why it's taking up
space which I'm broadly sympathetic to
the way it's Being Framed in this
reading
um then you can learn about a better way
of of of framing things so that they
take up space in this really fatalistic
kind of evil
um
uh way that that that that that that's
it that it whatever the spectacle yeah
whatever word we're gonna use basically
if you want to be a theorist it's better
to be a film director
than a writer yeah probably I mean I
mean this even goes back to rorty right
do you remember when we read the Richard
rorty he kind of made that point that
the things that actually make an impact
are the literature uh and movies and I
mean it's not exactly the same point but
but that but I do remember rorty's
making that kind of claim that
you know the theory that I think he
called habermas maybe the most correct
but also is going to have the least
impact in the world because you know
it's not uh it's it's very not
fascinating that's for sure yeah like I
think this text is seductive I have a
video coming out about this soon
I think I'm gonna call it nice I think
I'm gonna call it post-modernism is good
actually okay nice
but yeah that's my final thought so I
liked it I enjoyed it
um I felt like it was a breath of fresh
air like okay bodra does not get really
studied
he barely gets red maybe like a chapter
from simulacra and simulation
but this is some real [__] that I I
think it I think it deserves its time in
the Sun
though
well I mean there's a reason that that
no theorist would want to hear this
because he's just calling their job
stupid
but even people who are who are
interested obviously like we have a lot
of marxists in our audience and right
they're gonna hate it marxists may maybe
yeah sorry marxists uh for this one yeah
it's not not so hopeful for the for the
Marshall's point of view
or the anarchist point of view or any
kind of revolutionary point of view in a
way but maybe it's just more radical
the most radical
yeah like he says something don't bring
up something new Eric we're winding down
yeah you're trying to do it again
I mean just about the revolution isn't
there a quote in here about the
revolution you know the revolution on
the side of the object is going to be
obscure and Silent it's not going to be
something Grand invisible
he kind of has this I wish I could just
find the quote quickly but I can't it's
in there somewhere a withdrawal of the
will
yeah I mean that's that's the thing it's
like silence non-engagement I mean these
these we're adopting the strategies of
the objects were
I don't I don't know these are are these
strategies something we should can I say
that a strategy would be like a strategy
of of strategic non-engagement
strategic silence strategic you know
withdrawal into inertia I would prefer
not to and non-compliance yeah I really
did think of that that quote from the um
from uh the the what's his names
Bartleby yeah yeah yeah I have something
to conclude on because when we think of
strategy we think of oh what are we
going to do next to further the leftist
cause or something like that so an
interviewer actually asked in this
question this book is called fatal
strategies and the interviewer asks a
patron sent this to me so I'm not taking
credit for it oh cool but when you speak
of the strategy of the Fatal what
interests be most is the strategy what
is to be done
the interviewer asks and bodegaard
responds it's not really strategy
that's a play on words to dramatize the
total passage from the subject to the
object whether you call it the Revenge
of the object or the Evil Genius of
matter it's not representable but it's
power all the same in fact I would go
along with calling it The principle of
evil of irreconciliation the way the
good is the principle of reconciliation
that exists it's inextricable and it
cannot be destroyed so it's an
inevitability which is the fatality of
it is the world's gonna go the way that
it's gonna go
and you basically choose a side as a
strategy not as a strategy to become the
agent of history that changes things
and maybe that's relieving or maybe
that's depressing to you I kind of find
it a little bit relieving yeah I think I
kind of do too
I mean it's something
it's something else right like how do
you organizing it's better than oh did
you buy your clothes from Bangladesh
because then you're
you're becoming a subject of capitalism
and perpetuating the system like I'm I
don't know where I bought it from
I bought the Hanes shirt from Walmart
man yeah like it it's hard for me to
leave behind the idea that still you
know like improving
the workplace improving Healthcare these
sorts of things create social conditions
for revolutions and or at least better
participation in politics
it's hard for me to leave that behind
and I I don't know if both yards really
asking me to do that but
you know the idea of of
an upper class or a bourgeoisie having
power and the mass is Desiring that
power and some kind of Revolution
that's something he's saying is is not
you know the masses don't want Power
other politicians know that power is
the orchestration of its own
disappearance and that's why you know
the the politicians who are in the know
will you know not want to be in the
power position they'll put someone else
there like Donald Trump is a stooge
right he's he's just
in a sense he's just taking the fall for
the the establishments
but yeah you can throw Biden in there
and he's not even conscious most days
yeah same thing right like he's reneging
on so many promises he's made
he's gonna be hated for that I thought
we were wrapping this up Biden's an
object he doesn't even know he's there
that's the strategy Biden is the perfect
strategy of the object by not even
knowing you're there
that's funny all right well yeah we'll
end on that I guess be obscene that's
the that's the ending no BFC destroy the
scene it's all a show
don't buy into the show
income object all right
well guys we will wrap it on that note
been fun yeah
um I I covered each chapter of this book
on the video
prescription of the patreon if you're
interested in more so this was oh cool
this is basically two-thirds of one
chapter and I did Eight Episodes on the
entire book because it was so
fascinating he goes into so much other
stuff just like inventing political
subjects like the obese
what we could do we could do another
episode on on another chapter I'd be up
for that I'd like to I'd like to
introduce to you guys the obese because
it's it's funny
um anyway sounds fun we're done for now
that'll be awesome we're done for now
maybe we'll pick that up
take care everybody peace
all right
foreign
[Music]